we had two people at an event that were
blind this woman saw her face For the
First Time The Physicians that were in
the audience that were disbelievers they
were in tears they just could not
imagine that this could actually take
place it wasn't matter to matter you
know it wasn't 3D reality trying to
change 3D reality that was not it was it
was energy you have this amazing
evidence in scientific research evidence
is the loudest voice and I'm so
optimistic now that we actually can
actually find our way here that that
that we have to come together community
of a same Consciousness that isn't angry
they've overcome their anger it isn't
fearful they've overcome their fear
they're not suffering in pain they've
overcome that in their own personal work
and they're actually showing the world
what love looks like they're showing the
world what greatness looks like they're
demonstrating for the world they're not
talking about it philosophically do you
believe in that hundredth monkey Theory
it's not that I believe it and I know it
now because I'm seeing four people with
Raynard syndrome in one event all heal
that's a morphogenic field there